Encuentra la ecuación de la recta que es
paralela a la recta
"2x" menos "4y" igual a 8 y pasa por el punto 3, 0.
Dado que la recta que nos piden es
paralela a esta recta...
es paralela a esta recta...
Eso significa que ambas tienen la misma pendiente,
básicamente nos piden encontrar la ecuación
de la recta que tiene la misma pendiente de
esta recta y que pasa por el punto 3, 0.
Empecemos por calcular cuál es la
pendiente de esta recta
y la manera más fácil es poner la ecuación en la forma pendiente ordenada.
Tenemos entonces que la ecuación es "2x"
menos "4y" igual a 8,
lo que tenemos que hacer es despejar "y", poner la ecuación en la forma "y" igual a "mx" más "b".
Sumemos entonces, o mejor dicho, restemos
"2x" a ambos lados de la ecuación,
así tenemos entonces que del lado
izquierdo esto se cancela,
nos queda "-4y" y del lado derecho "-2x" más 8.
Y estoy poniendo "-2x" primero para tenerla
en la forma "mx" más "b".
Ahora dividimos ambos lados de la ecuación
entre -4, para que podamos despejar la "y".
Entonces dividiendo todo entre -4, del lado
izquierdo nos queda, estos términos se cancelan,
nos queda "y", del lado derecho nos queda
-2 entre -4 es igual a 1/2, entonces nos queda
1/2 de "x" y 8 entre -4 es -2, así que tendríamos
que sumar más -2, o simplemente menos 2.
Así que lo que hemos hecho es tan solo reescribir
la ecuación de esta recta,
pero como ya la tenemos en la forma "mx" más "b", podemos identificar que ésta de aquí...
ésta de aquí, es la pendiente...
ésta de aquí es la pendiente "m".
Así es que para la recta que estamos buscando,
ésta es la pendiente, por lo cual la ecuación
de dicha recta va a tener la forma,
"y" igual a 1/2 de "x" más la ordenada al origen.
No va a ser exactamente esta ecuación, no
va a ser esta misma ordenada al origen,
pero va a tener la misma pendiente.
Tienen distinta ordenada al origen, pero tienen
la misma pendiente, son rectas paralelas.
Así es que ahora necesitamos calcular el
valor de "b" y para eso vamos a utilizar esta
información que tenemos aquí.
Cuando "x" es igual a 3, en esa recta, cuando
"x" es igual a 3, "y" es igual a 0,
así es que cuando "x" es igual a 3, "y" es igual a 0.
Sustituyamos esos valores en la ecuación,
0 es igual a 1/2 por 3 más "b", es decir,
en esta recta, el valor de la ordenada al
origen, lo voy a calcular
sustituyendo los valores del punto
por donde pasa, el punto 3, 0.
Así tenemos, 0 es igual a 3/2 más "b".
Vamos a despejar "b", restamos 3/2 a ambos lados y ¿qué tenemos?
Del lado izquierdo nos queda -3/2, del lado
derecho estos términos se cancelan y nos queda "b".
Ya tenemos que el valor de "b" es igual  a -3/2,
tenemos ya la ecuación de la recta paralela a ésta y que pasa por el punto 3, 0.
La ecuación de la recta que estamos buscando
es, "y" igual a 1/2 de "x"...
1/2 de "x" más mi "b" y la "b" es -3/2... -3/2.
Y hemos concluido.
De hecho si te interesa, podemos graficar
estas dos rectas y verificar que son paralelas.
Voy a hacer aquí unos ejes, voy a hacer un
esbozo muy rápido de las rectas.
Entonces aquí tenemos mi eje "y", mi eje
"x" y vamos a graficar las rectas.
Tenemos la recta "2x" menos "4y" igual a 8,
la vamos a tomar de esta manera,
de la forma "mx" más "b".
Esto sería... checamos que la ordenada al
origen es -2 y vamos a graficarla.
Aquí tenemos la ordenada al origen que es
-2 y la pendiente que es 1/2,
quiere decir que avanzamos dos hacia la derecha y uno hacia arriba... dos a la derecha y uno hacia arriba
trazamos la línea aproximadamente donde estaría
esa pendiente de 1/2 y aquí tenemos la recta.
La otra recta, la otra recta tiene una
ordenada al origen de -3/2,
vamos a ubicar la ordenada al origen de -3/2, si aquí era -2, -3/2 está pegadita...
pegadita a donde estaba la otra y la pendiente es la misma pendiente de 1/2.
trazamos la recta, está muy pegada una de otra,
pero son rectas paralelas.
Y así se ven estas rectas, son paralelas
pero tiene diferente ordenada al origen.